there's this massive sort of blind spot
in political debate in general but
especially lately among the so-called
anti SJW free speech warrior types
including some of the followers of the
intellectual dark web so-called which is
that they seem to either ignore or not
understand that most things in life are
not black and white most political
issues aren't black and white and it's
the gray area where almost all of life
exists and this isn't me giving you some
cultural relativism thing or some pop
post modernist stuff or rehashing my
piece from a few months ago explaining
that movements that focus on principles
miss the point that the real hard work
is really in figuring out specific
situations rather than just coming up
with some list of principles I actually
want to focus in today on some of the
memes that have spread around this and
within this alt-right overlapping with
anti sjw sort of Enclave and as an
example of what I mean even before I do
that I want to make another point most
things being grey area doesn't mean that
the truth is somewhere in the middle of
two extremes right that's a really
important thing to understand the truth
about 9/11 for example isn't the halfway
point between the so called official
story and Bush did 9/11 or Jews did 9/11
right
it's fallacious to say that and when I
say that things are mostly gray area I
do not mean that to find the truth you
just come up with like an average of
positions on the issue okay so let's go
through an example it has become really
really popular to attack so-called
identity politics is done by the left
right the new right loves to slam
identity politics let's ignore for a
second the hypocrisy of the alt-right
being fundamentally an identity movement
since this is about gray area not
hypocrisy but there are also hypocrites
on this issue and the right has come up
with the position that identity politics
are bad the left should be against
identity politics you're either a
regressive leftist who loves identity
politics or you're a brave leftist who's
willing and able
to denounce identity politics and the
truth is that the sense on this issue is
what I've pointed out before identity
politics can mean many different things
identity politics can be productive or
destructive but identity matters so what
we should do is carefully listen to
people who speak about their experiences
as members of a particular identity
group included in our evaluation of
issues without making identity a sort of
trump card as Nathan J Robinson recently
wrote in a very good piece in current
affairs
it's not about are you pro or anti
social justice warrior right social
justice warrior has become this
worthless pejorative but on identity
politics we can understand that the
stories of those with membership and an
identity group are important but they
don't have some kind of ultimate
authority right nor should they limit
open debate or discussion about issues
it's a great area it's boring right if
you're asked are you pro or anti sjw on
right-wing hate radio what I gave is a
very boring answer but it's an accurate
answer let's talk about another example
popular one cultural appropriation I
received a call I think it was last week
about cultural appropriation during live
calls do I think cultural appropriation
is a problem is it bad or good do I
think that we should be for or against
cultural appropriation Breanna joy gray
as Nathan Robinson writes in his article
in current affairs has found the gray
area on this right which is listen if
someone is incorporating using or
appropriating elements of somebody
else's culture or race that's nothing to
criticize if there is exploitation or
disrespect of a disadvantaged groups
culture including for dishonest
financial gain then yeah we should be
critical of that so again hey man are
you for or against cultural
appropriation well I'm for respectful
use of diverse cultures cuisine or arts
or dress or hairstyles or whatever and
I'm against disrespect and exploitation
oh that's boring man either you're for
or against cultural appropriation white
privilege another example does white
privilege exists is often the debate a
common question in those debates is a
white guy will say tell me specific
how I've benefited from white privilege
if you can't it's because it doesn't
exist race along with gender and age are
characteristics that we immediately
identify when we meet someone or
interact with someone right you don't
even have to try you see the cashier at
the grocery store you are immediately
understanding that cashier as being a
young Hispanic female for example right
humans immediately recognize those
elements of identity so it would be
insane to pretend that there wouldn't be
subconscious judgments that are applied
and that society as a whole
sees those characteristics in ways that
could be positive or negative or neutral
so that is a reality let's recognize the
historical advantages that white people
are those perceived as white have had
for example in the US for a long time
now but that doesn't have to dictate our
politics it doesn't have to subjugate
other avenues among which we should be
considering how politics should be done
or economic justice or education or
whatever else white privilege is a thing
but it doesn't dictate a specific
political path forward race is a factor
privilege is a factor but there
shouldn't be any sort of drawing of a
line a line in the sand I guess we could
call it on the issue because there's
really no line to be drawn and that is
the false black/white dichotomy that
some of these new movements are looking
for economics very popular among this
anti SJW crossover group is to be
anti-communist and anti-socialist they
are capitalists freedom and free markets
is what they claimed before and of
course the truth is that unregulated
capitalism is a disaster of inequality
and plunder but socialism does ignore
the reality of concepts like Pareto
distribution and prices law which tell
us that expecting equality of outcome no
matter what we do is either unrealistic
or not a good thing because of how it
would have to be forced so it turns out
that the societies that end up with the
best balance of happiness and equality
and standard of living are the ones that
have a version of capitalism that is
capitalistic enough to encourage
entrepreneurship and innovation but they
spend enough money on social welfare
socializing some of those elements so
that you avoid the levels of inequality
and poverty that are destructive to
society that's boring right that's
boring but it's not a black and white
world and this reality has been lost on
this new generation of right-wingers and
of some on the left on the right on the
left as well I'm not afraid to criticize
the left on this issue or any other
issue but it's sort of notable right now
among this anti SJW all right
intellectual dark web sort of crossover
group the truth is often quite boring
because the truth is usually it's
complicated and that depends and one of
the reasons that anti and
pseudo-intellectual ism is so popular
right now as we've been talking about
for months if not years is that it
purports to give people simple and
straightforward answers about things
going on in the world and sometimes
comforting answers to issues that are
really far more complicated become
popular by their very nature and I want
to hear from you about this send me your
thoughts I'm not doing post modernist
stuff I'm not doing the truth is
somewhere in the middle fallacies what
I'm telling you is that most issues
don't exist exist in black and white
they are gray areas and this new
movement call it the intellectual dark
web call it the alt-right call it
whatever you want is completely ignoring
that the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership